our nation was founded on a bedrock  principle that we are all created equal  Seneca Falls Selma and Stonewall  ordinary people can do extraordinary  things  I would got you all figured out grew up  in Kansas and mama probably baked apple  pies the other body this is Benny then  welcome to New York  don't use your real name who is run by  the mob or an organization that fights  for gay rights  are you looking at [ __ ]  this is what we're fighting we have to  fight in a peaceful way resist the  radicalism that I  starting to take home  I have not seen one dream come true from  precipice you baby there is no hope  there is no family Danny  I like being there  these kids have nothing left to lose  that's not the way daddy they still  having a parade commemorate the fighting  and they're gonna call it the gay  liberation March I'm coming  hard bargain even hard walking before  you do say